we're expecting dramatic testimony today
in the Harvey Weinstein trial from
actress Annabella Shira The Sopranos
actress is one of more than 80 women to
accuse the disgraced mogul of misconduct
she says he raped her in the early 90s
Weinstein faces charges involving two
other women including rape and sexual
assault now he claims everything he has
done was consensual
Jericka Duncan is outside the courthouse
in New York City was more on this story
tarika how does this trial played out so
far do you think well you know this is
still early in this trial and already
the defense made a motion for a mistrial
they accused the prosecution of trying
to poison the jury in its opening
statements by referring to Harvey
Weinstein as a predatory monster now the
judge denied that motion allowing for
this landmark case which spurred the me2
movement to continue yet another day
Harvey Weinstein ditched his walker to
enter court for opening statements the
67 year old's long-awaited trial will be
decided by a jury of seven men and five
women they are faced with two narratives
prosecutors presented graphic accounts
from six women of Weinstein's alleged
sexual attacks two of those accounts
resulted in criminal charges in one
incident they claimed Weinstein had
shown up to a woman's hotel room
uninvited in his underwear and another
they say Weinstein injected himself with
erection medication before allegedly
raping a woman and in the third case
Weinstein allegedly offered a woman's
sex with him and his assistant
explaining quote this is how the
industry works but Weinstein's team
counters many of those relationships
were consensual or even transactional
one of Weinstein's attorneys show the
jury words used from text emails and
other forms of communication in court
including a note where one woman who
accused Weinstein of rape described
Weinstein as her casual boyfriend
texting him four years after the alleged
rape quote I love you I always do but I
hate feeling like a booty call attorney
Gloria Allred who represents three of
the women who will testify in this case
says she's confident the truth will come
to light in court the defense says while
there are two realities there's really
only one reality and that's the reality
that we're going to see as it comes out
through evidence Jericka Duncan
reporting thanks